this used to be his home and a shop that
provided him income now all that Anna
Salman has left is rubble his house
collapsed after flash floods hit his
town of lje in Sudan's Khartoum state on
Monday the water destroyed most of their
belongings this shop was the only means
I had to support myself and my family in
the house was the only place we had to
live all of that is gone now and there's
nothing I can do but say it's God's will
the floods have destroyed at least 700
houses here according to the town's
Disaster Response Committee leaving more
than 300 families displaced Sudanese
authorities say rains and flash floods
in the past two weeks have destroyed
over 12,000 homes across the country
most of the damage is in poor
neighborhoods with shoddy drainage
infrastructure basic services have also
been affected life has become hard there
is no electricity the water lines have
been affected there are no shops working
no bakeries working everything has
become hard more rain and a rise in
river water levels are expected in the
coming days adding to concerns of more
floods to come but that's not all flash
floods have not only destroyed homes
here in El Jani
they've also turned roads like this one
into rivers and because it can take days
sometimes weeks for them to dry out it's
feared stagnant waters will bring
diseases over the past few years health
workers have recorded an increase in the
number of malaria and cholera fatalities
due to stagnant waters during rainy
seasons affected residents blamed the
former government out stood in April of
neglect
now opposition leaders say steps need to
be taken to ensure that what happened in
Angelli
doesn't happen again because we only you
know having this registration in place
we need some deeds we need to build new
dams new barriers located so as to
prevent floods coming from the far east
of a gayly it is more than having
legislation in place it is about
political will
it is about restructuring the area
coming
new ideas to prevent any floods in the
future for Ernest who has to pick up the
pieces to rebuild his home starting over
won't be easy and with the rainy season
not yet over
he hopes no more flash floods come to
take away what little he has left
Hiba Morgan al Jazeera Horton